hello everyone
so I am Luca I'm a devops engineer and I
like to think of me after as an open
source and just and today we will talk
about this robots
uh so what is this Dropbox this Dropbox
is a tool uh written in persexual uh
very simple which wraps podman or docker
to have an abstraction of the
complexities of these tools and create
environments that seamlessly integrate
with the host
so
it was born inspired by the great work
of uh fedora's toolbox and
but I needed that solution that could
work both with parman Docker or in
future with other container managers for
example
and so a solution also there could be
distribution agnostic both on the host
side and the guest side
and generally speaking something that
could make easier
to to use software that wasn't packaged
as flat Parker was an app
so how could we think of it so if you
think of flat Packers your Hub your app
which is Unbound from the base operating
system or Docker as a service which is
unbounder and isolated from the base
operating system this Dropbox or a pet
container is an entire user space
I'm bound from the base operating system
but still very integrated with the base
the base host
you could think it
seems like CH would with extra steps and
you uh could be right but actually not
so
uh as I was saying it it uses
um uh container manager so it's simpler
to use than simple see through the CLI
experience is a little bit more polished
and the container managers are bottle
tested they are used in the past years
in the cloud environment and they are
very very very reliable
and they integrate an easy to use image
management system
and you can tap in the healthy ecosystem
of container images for the cloud so you
can have a lot of
various operating system and versions
and most of the time they are even
officially
maintained by the the main projects
so we have to for now just to container
manager supported which is podman Docker
podman can run in rootless mode
uh so no sudo required or convert
running root for mode if you need it
Docker can only run in root full mode
for now
they are much faster and lighter than
VMS and the the goal is to use them as a
complete replacement
for your CLI in the everyday use
optionally they can even act as a
separated system uh having a separate
system distance or in a distance and
even have complete graphical session
a word of of warning this is not a
security enhancing Tool uh this is not
like flat pack that send boxes your
stuff so you are
more more secure
this is not more not less secure than
your base operating system so
you have some advantages while using a
rootless distortbox using podman because
even inside the your container you can
use sudo but you never are really rude
on the base operating system you're
still our your user so you have a little
bit of an advantage there there but for
for a root root through this robots root
inside the container is root outside of
it so be careful
uh the integration is quite tight with
the base base host
obviously uh it shares the the home
directory of the of the user but we have
also integration with Wayland uh audio
both pipe wire and pools uh SSH agent
gpg agent we have the user system the
integration so from inside the store box
you can just use season CTL Dash user
and use your
host
ccnd you can use the the host debus
session user session access for
removable devices
so slash Dev and
as a as I was saying optionally isolated
season instance it automatically
generates desktop entries for the
contains that you create so it it's
easier to access them you have them in
titling your application list and there
is integration so you can launch host
command from the container and vice
versa so we can have a tight integration
both ways
the the usage was thought to be as
simple as possible so the main goal was
to obstruct the complexities so uh
you have just some basic management
commands you have your create enter list
removements top for the containers
everything can work without specifying
any flag any anything the they are
saying default I think they are saying
defaults
you have you can choose your your image
you can choose your name you can even
choose a custom home for for the host so
you don't Litter your home with DOT
files for example
and I also add some utilities one one is
the upgrade command so you can it will
just uh cycle through all your distro
boxes and use the package manager of
each one to keep them updated like a
center hub you have the ephemeral diesel
boxes which are basically similar to the
docker apartment run dash dash RM which
will create enter and when you exit
destroy the temporary container which is
very useful for testing or for
um
you know playing around and there is the
generator entry command to create this
desktop icons for for your containers
so which are the use cases for this type
of of tool
obviously the immovable desktop is one
of the use cases I used one so
um you are it's not really easy when you
need the tool to just do you know go
install it because you need to reboot
and so if you are on endless OS Fedora
Sylvia silver blue or kenoite and micro
s and lately I've added support for the
steam deck you can have your mutable
environment and play around with it but
even if you are not on an immutable
operating system you can have the
advantages of
uh
[Music]
diminishing the number of packages in
the base operating system so you have
less moving parts that can break
um so updates are more likely to be
successful uh you have a New Zealand can
that can be easily replaced and it's
easier to make risk producible
user length for for if you destroy hope
a lot for example
but talking of apps
some maps are specific to some
distribution and maybe they are not
tested on other versions of the scene
distribution or not supported in a newer
or older systems
or simply yeah they are not supported uh
maybe you can use a tool like alien to
pass a Dev to our RPM or vice versa but
then you have dependency that can cause
the a system breakage
and maybe for this app there is no flat
pack there isn't an app or this app is
not packaged at all maybe it's only on
the Aur on copper obser or a PPA
or generally speaking you don't want to
litter your system with a lot of stuff
that maybe you don't use anymore
so
this is useful and another use case
which actually is why I started
developing this was having an Enterprise
laptop
and sometimes in Enterprise you have
some
regulations that you have to follow and
maybe you cannot be super user on your
laptop
but you need your tools to work maybe uh
you you are devops engineer a software
engineer as his admin and you need your
stuff to work you can do that in your
containerized environment
or generally speaking make some matching
distros you may be on a LTS stable
release and you want latest software for
some reason or you are on bleeding edge
release and you need a very old software
for some reason and this boxes can
ensure compatibility up almost 10 years
back in time
so the diversity of distribution are
about 60 if we can combinations and
permutations of version and
distribution themselves they go go back
to Debian 7 Center 7 Ubuntu 14 or for
they are the oldest uh on the on the
list you can go older if you have custom
images for example because maybe the
the mirrors of the repo are not working
anymore
uh but mainly if
um if you go to back in time like on
Debian 6 and Center 6 uh the Liberty is
a little bit too old and won't work with
uh kernels after 411 and you will need
that grab entry for the VC School
but it's doable
um and obviously there is support for of
all the latest distribution Arch Linux
for the Rawhide Tumbleweed uh Ubuntu
debians table
and you can mix and match uh however you
like
uh container side the having
the the only
dependency is really having a posix
compliant bnsh and having one of the
supported package manager
why a package manager is needed well
if no if you take a cloud image for
example of Ubuntu is only 30 megabytes
and it's really really small and lacks a
lot of software that maybe you expect on
even on a minimal install so what I do
during the initialization of the the
container I installed all the basic
stuff that you I user expects even for
for a command line environment
so a package manager is needed
if something is not supported just open
a future request or if you are if you
are in if you want to help open a pool
request every contribution is always
welcome
uh performance wise
I did some tests using the phonics test
suite and
it was on a fedora 35 host using
affidora 35 container and a clear Linux
container
and as you can see the overhead of
Fedora 35 container on top of the dollar
35 was really minimal we were between
one and two percent of the host
performance but the red part is the
clear Linux container the clear Linux
container is consistently faster than
the host itself
because of the optimization that clear
Linux brings so
is low enough to
reap the benefits of having something
like that
so talking of apps uh you don't want to
always open your terminal enter the
distro box and launch your apps Maybe
so I've provided an export command that
will integrate the applications from
inside the container
out to The Host
the basic one you you can export apps
single binaries or
user system D services
we will see in a demo later but
for example this is a simple Arch
container which has a atom installed
inside you want it outside of it you
just export Dash Dash app and you will
have your atom uh or your app outside of
the container easily accessible and it
will be out all automatic for for the
launch and it will be transparent to you
and same is for binaries and systemd
services so they will have just um the
system the services will have like um
prefix which will be the name of the
container that is running that one but
you can just use it from your host same
for the binaries you just put them in
your path and you can use them
transparently really
so let's show something
I don't know if I can
maybe white is better
so
let's do a normal terminal
so starting from here
let's Zoom it
starting from here we can list our
diesel boxes
simply by listing them
there will be green if they are running
there will be yellow if they are not and
for example an example of application I
would like to show is
bitwig
we it's a
digital
audio workstation
okay
actually bitwig is
um
distributed as a Debian a Deb package
for Ubuntu 24 app
or a flat back so obviously you can use
the flat pack but sometimes you cannot
use the flap plug for example if you
want to use a tool called yab Bridge
which lets you use plugins from Windows
inside the Linux digital audio
workstation so
to you to just install it we can
I created previously
um Ubuntu
distro box
and just you enter the Ubuntu One
you can see it will the the first time
it will do some steps with uh
the the very first time you create the
distort box and launch it is a bit slow
uh because there is the First Step
installing basic packages obviously
depending on your internet connection it
has to go and fetch the packages but the
other times you enter it for example in
our exit and enter it again
it's quite fast
so let's install
the bit week
I should have
the common
so this one is the command to solid from
the between the documentation really
enables the 386 architecture and
installed it really
um
awfully yeah
and as you can see there are some other
outputs
there are a series of hooks that this
Showbox implements inside the gas
container to make it work with the host
integration so you don't have like
read-only paths or
generally speaking you have maybe some
some type of
uh conflicts
so let's launch it
beat
so it's running
what you're saying
I'll continue
and
yeah I mean
okay it's on the other screen sorry
there it is
and it has full audio integration with
the host
uh I don't really see what I'm doing uh
yeah so it's working as expected and you
have an icon in the
in the in the dock I I will quickly
change the
uh the
screen sharing option just to show you
no no not a good idea
uh sorry for that
uh yeah so I could
um I could show you uh how to integrate
it but uh probably you won't see the
the
you won't see the the icon
but let's try anyway exit and if you
digital box
export
uh dash dash up
midweek
so it was feedback that it was exported
you can see it in the
local
share application
you will see that there is a Ubuntu
24 bigquig dot desktop so
you have to trust me it's my in my
application list now uh you can export
the binary of bitwig itself so if we go
which bit wink
in the studio
so if I want to export it I can do this
box export
binary this one
in
I don't know local
bin for example
and if I exit the container
so now I am on the host I can
launch between Studio
directly from the host it will be
transparent so if you install other
types of
of binaries like I don't know ffmpeg or
npv something like that it will be like
having it on on the host itself
and as I was saying we can also export
um services
so we can I created
um
a distro box for for the service which
is a sync thing it's a synchronization
uh files Equalization program if we
install it
yeah
this one will create a
system the service but you cannot really
use systemd Services inside the
container if you don't create uh one
with a separate systemd so what we can
do is
Easter box export
service sync thing
it will inform you that you have now
this new
um uh this new service which you can
just see like
so
now it's not running
so you can restart it
demo reload
as you can see now it's running it's
running inside the container but you
access it from The Host
systemd
and
well it's
available here
simply
so it's pretty transparent and you can
simply uh
no
access what it would be otherwise
difficult to access really another
example being on uh in this case on an
immutable file system
having the possibility of installing
rootful containers
is important
for example
list dash dash route
you can see I'm running a libbert
container
what is it let's enter it
sorry
this one is a an alma Linux container
which has a separate system distance
this one is completely separate from the
host and you can have
your own services in your like
libert
so this one is really useful in at least
in my case because installing Liberty
and all the dependency is quite
demanding and it's a lot of stuff
this is just simpler for me I open a
container I can dnf or yam or whatever
install whatever I need
and then you can just use it as a normal
distribution much more similar for
example an lxc for example where you
have a complete system inside and I can
use this manager
to access it
and view manager itself is in another
District box which is my main dish box
so it's working as expected and
it helps with the software availability
it helps with the incompatibilities and
with testing also because you can
test on various type of
all the environments much easier and you
don't have the quirks of you know being
maybe sandboxed you cannot launch a
graphical application or you cannot
launch I don't know uh
some type of of process
so there are also ways to manage it
graphically
there is a an emerging app called atoms
where is it
where
this is from uh Mirko bombing great guy
and this uh lets you install from Flat
Hub this application and then you can
manage it
[Music]
simply from from this application you
can have a console you can
just add your terminal
um launch also application from here
oh yeah it's already open
um
you can launch application for me so
it's a very neat way I really like it uh
way to manage them so you have your
command line you have your graphical
applications
and yeah you can even uh I will not demo
this because it's a little bit
complicated and unstable but you can
have
um
separate instances of
um
of gnome
for example
this is a Centos 7 machine where
it's running the latest gnome inside the
distro box and you can just select it at
login time
you can do the same with KDE
so it can be also useful in case you are
you are stuck on on a new distribution
to to have access to one of the latest
softwares this is a little bit
experimental still uh the integration
here is really Advanced so there are
still Corner cases but it's
doable and
so back to the
so what's that what are the next steps
for for the project one of the of the
missing staff is a ruthless Docker and
uh container D plus learned CTL support
sadly I cannot still use them because uh
there is uh Miss it's missing
um an option for the username space keep
ID which is useful to
to map yourself inside the container so
you don't have mismatching identities
um
adding alternate backends there is
Catman which is a CH Street manager that
I wrote
and there is Cave Run VM to to run micro
VMS on top of this so you can for
example have your Centos 7 inside the
micro VM sentosate and the important
thing is it's really useful for if you
have to do kernel development for
example
adding Us in boxing mode which can seem
a bit counterintuitive because until now
I was talking how much it is integrated
with base host
but having the bare minimum integration
just to have your graphical application
working but having us unboxing so you
can
trust it a little bit more is useful
obviously adding more tests
right now I have
a cup some pipelines of GitHub to
continuously test the compatibility of
all the distribution that I declare in
the documentation and yeah having better
CLI ux
feedback is always welcome no
so tldr
these are books is a nice tool to enable
both backward and forward compatibility
in the software
adds you the freedom to use whatever
distribution you want and without having
you know to install everything each time
and generally speaking making you more
more comfortable with your own machine
if you want to contribute uh it's on
GitHub and there is a contributing
document that you can read and helps you
to
to have the the basics for the
contribution
yeah report bugs typos
plenty of them
improvements I'm always open to
constructive criticism and improvements
and yeah if you feel like contribution
they'll contribute it's
always welcome
uh I'm listening here for whoever
downloads the PDF there is a list of
um useful links
um on
how to use it so there is the distro Box
documentation uh I spent
a lot of time on that so it should be
quite exhaustive there is the benchmarks
and there is a couple of videos by
George Castro on how he uses on Fedora
silver blue and how he manages to
integrate it with his own workflow
thank you very much and yeah this was
this works
we have eight minutes uh for for the
questions
so if you have questions uh I'm here
sure there's a microphone
two questions first one do you have GPU
support
can you fully lose use on for example
Nvidia card
yeah yeah so
the the hardware is passed through the
the container
obviously you have to install the
drivers
inside the container and generally
speaking for now I still don't install
the Mesa
drivers I was thinking of it ISO even
the guys of Fedora toolbox just today
they pushed an update where they
installed the basic open source drivers
which is a really good idea and they
want to implement it also which is a bit
more difficult on my side because I need
to have compatibility on all the range
of distro so I need mainly check what's
the package name of them for the Nvidia
part if you have drivers on the host and
inside you can
don't use that I I have
um in there is a matrix channel of this
Showbox and a telegram Channel and some
of the user have Nvidia cards and they
use it inside the container because they
install Steam inside the container and
they work for Play from inside the
container so yeah it works
okay and second question you told about
removable USB devices can you add a USB
device while the container is running
yeah yeah it's transparent when you plug
it it pops
May generally speaking it's just
mounting
inside the container so it's something
pops out in in Dev you see it in the
container it's not a problem all right
thank you thank you
any other questions
cool
any questions from online
okay I can close them
thank you very much
[Applause]